bueno no se sabe muy bien lo que van a
hacer los talibanes hay que esperar a
que formen el gobierno la noche que van
a formar un gobierno
que será islámico riguroso y que se
basada en la ley islámica pero no
sabemos qué normas establecerán esa ley
islámica y qué interpretación harán de
esa legislación islámica
hay que recordar que ya en los años 90
cuando los talibanes estuvieron
estuvieron en el poder ellos también
insistían de que respetaban los derechos
de las mujeres pero también
establecieron que las mujeres se tenían
que quedar en casa por razones de
seguridad es decir estamos en las mismas
estamos repitiendo el mismo discurso
ellos vuelven a decir que bueno que sí
que las mujeres pueden participar en la
vida pública pero que ahora como la
seguridad no es buena en afganistán que
es mejor que se queden en casa es decir
yo creo que
van a imponer pues pues eso que las
mujeres no puedan trabajar fuera de casa
no puedan estudiar y tal vez puedan
permitir que las niñas sí que vayan al
colegio pero bueno en afganistán y ahora
ya hasta antes de la llegada de los
talibanes al poder niños y niñas iban a
clases separadas si ahora en la
comunidad internacionales se encuentra
en una encrucijada por un lado las
mujeres piden que no se reconozcan al
gobierno talibán y por el otro un
eventual reconocimiento sería una
herramienta de presión política para
exigir garantías para las mujeres que
deben hacer los países de occidente ante
este dilema mónica
yo creo que los países de occidente
nunca les ha interesado la situación de
las mujeres en afganistán ahora todos
estamos escandalizados con lo que está
pasando en afganistán pero es que la
situación de las mujeres en afganistán
ya era dramática con la presencia de
tropas internacionales en los niveles de
violencia familiar en afganistán son
increíbles y eso se conocía por parte de
la cuenta de la comunidad internacional
y no se ha hecho absolutamente nada no
se hizo absolutamente nada para
presionar al govern afgano a pesar que
el gobierno afgano dependía en esos
momentos totalmente al cien por cien de
la ayuda económica extranjera
y ahora claro ahora parte de esa
violencia familiar brutal se van a
encontrar con la violencia en las calles
es decir que no van a poder evitar
siquiera salir a la calle a para poder
trabajar yo creo que la comuna
internacional a hacer lo que siempre ha
hecho es decir actuar según sus propios
intereses no y no va a tener en cuenta
para nada ni a las mujeres afganas ni
creo yo a la conjunto de la población
afgana ahora mónica brevemente cómo fue
su experiencia viviendo como mujer en
afganistán
bueno como mujer extranjera en
afganistán y periodista por una parte
tienes ventajas y por otra parte tienes
desventajas las ventajas al ser un país
tan sumamente conservador y machista
pues consideran que no eres peligrosa e
incluso muchas veces te dejan entrar a
lugares que a un hombre no les dejarían
entrar yo me podía presentar en un
ministerio sin tener ninguna entrevista
concertada y por el hecho de ser mujer
pues decían ay pobrecita está fuera en
la calle bajo el sol esperando pues la
dejamos pasar sí
en otras ocasiones lógicamente si te
mueves en un país en el que básicamente
te encuentras hombres en todos los
escenarios y en la vida pública pues
lógicamente los riesgos los riesgos
sobre todo de abusos sexuales son mucho
mayores que en otro lugar